what's up patrick how are we doing man
how you doing i'm doing all right
we're rocking and rolling on the ramsay
show it's uh
opportunity to talk to you on your show
i appreciate you taking my call you got
it brother so what's up man how can i
help
so i've been married for 11 years got
three kids my wife
i've been divorced twice i've had
problems in relationships but i'm trying
to make this one work
um hey hey i don't pause it right there
thank you for that patrick
thank you for that i've talked to too
many guys in your situation
that would roll their eyes and say yet
again i'm getting screwed on this deal
or i'm getting hosed on this deal or
whatever
and your first words to me are i'm
trying to make this work
and so i appreciate your vulnerability
there dude that takes a lot
is that new patrick uh it's it's
new ish okay uh hey i've been i've been
trying to make it work on the uh on the
third time now
and the fourth and the fifth hey there
we go
every day is a new chance to start over
all right man so how can i help
so the problem i have is i've come to
the end of my rope and i get angry and
mad and upset and frustrated and
want to nuke the whole thing and let go
but
i'm asked to hold on and i do
but i just feel like my wife's checked
out
yeah i would imagine so based on just
what you just told me
so i i i mean if
somebody who i loved and had chained
myself to it hitched myself to
got angry and just wanted to cash out
every time yeah i would be checked out
too i mean i can imagine that's a
rollercoaster and a whiplash so brother
why do you get angry and yell and scream
and
say i'm out i just feel like i'm
dragging this thing out by myself she
spends the majority of time i see her on
the back porch
scrolling on her phone or watching
videos and
i mean [ __ ] she hadn't sit down at the
dinner table me and the kids for over a
year
and how long have you been with her
we've been married 11
11 years okay so what is it about you
what is it about your family environment
that she wants no part of
i don't know you gotta know you've been
with over a decade
i think it's just distractions i know
but what does she need to distract
herself from
i don't know what about you
is she distracting herself from
accountability i mean i try to hold her
accountable for
responsibilities that she's not doing
and
okay give me an example of that
uh she's a stay-at-home mom uh she
has a hard time keeping up with the
house keeping up with the kids
keeping up with the kids clothes
routines
i mean it's gotten better but it's just
a challenge to keep
on task on track to grow
to be responsible to be accountable
to say yeah i'm going to do this and
then it gets done
and it's i don't know what she's running
from i mean
we've had knock down drag outs we've had
reconciliations we've had
i left for 30 days and came back
because i didn't want to leave the
family yeah but that was
two three years ago and i know she
looks back on it and this last
anniversary was a good one
and we've made some steps but i just
don't
see the work i don't see the commitment
i don't see the
the accountability the response i don't
see it how come your first marriage
didn't work brother
um i was young and stupid
elaborate got married uh i got married
as a young marine
uh deployed came back uh things were
fast and loose and it just
was stupid to get married in first place
you didn't answer my question that was
excellent evasion but you'd answer my
question did you cheat on her
uh yes yeah okay
so why did your second marriage work
uh she fell in love with somebody while
i was deployed okay came back got
married
she separated and married him okay
and what was it about this woman that
you're with now that made
giving it a third shot sound good
um well this one we got we were dating
again i was
coming off my second marriage and
going to the bars doing the thing and
ended up pregnant
so i wanted to make it work make sure
that
my child had a father and a mother
um and we considered abortion and
we both didn't want to do that okay um
and so we've we've pushed through and
we've had two more kids and
you know nine more years after that and
a couple houses new job
so i mean we've pushed
but you know
i'm sick of pushing yeah you know i can
hear that
and i promise you with everything i got
brother she's sick of being pushed
that's why i stopped pushing but leaving
it go
and just kind of set goals out there
hasn't worked either
i mean i've separated bank accounts
because the financial responsibility
isn't there
um hey listen listen is she done
no that's the thing she she says she's
not done she wants to work it out she
wants
she wants to keep working okay and the
way you've described
your wife to me as though you're
describing a teenage daughter
that you can't get under control
i feel that way she is no more your
partner in raising family
and just trying to suck the joy
out of life the the
wreckage that life is just misery after
misery and that's what partners can do
for each other when their marriage is
just
rad as they just find joy
is you have put her in line with one as
another child
and you might feel like you have to but
she's another kid with goals and
expectations and achievements that she
needs to accomplish
in order to make sure your house looks
the way it needs to be and that your
her body looks the way it needs to be
and your sex life needs to be in your
part
all those things and at some point she
checked out
possibly early on
and for most of us i don't want to over
gender this but most of our
us men we know one thing and that's to
push harder
and if we're losing a fight then we
think we need to
swing harder and kick harder and go for
takedowns harder
and you just said it perfectly i'm tired
of pushing man and i want to honor that
this relationship can handle no more
pushing
and if you back up 10 steps 15 steps and
you
look at this woman not as a problem to
fix
or as somebody to get in line but as
somebody to sit next to and hold their
hand and say baby i'm so sorry can we we
got to start over from square one
and what you've got now is a
relationship that's over 10 years right
so y'all are
in a tough window you got three kids how
old are your kids
uh six nine and ten oh brother y'all are
in it right you've got
five thousand activities all day every
day
some kids running in there yelling and
screaming the other kids
saying everybody shut up and there's
moods everywhere right you're in it
right
and you've got this woman who's at home
who's desperate to be seen
and known and to be loved at a
vulnerable level
and she's being given tasks and when she
fails the tasks you take
away the task and say i'll do it myself
you see how she's
almost as though she's a member of one
of your units
instead of your wife i do but i've taken
those away i used to do that and i've
stopped and i've
asked her what her goals are what she
wants to accomplish what she's trying to
do to grow
i've tried to include her in the
conversation to include
include her in you know her finances
getting her
stuff in order on her own time on her
own accord
i've stopped pushing i've stopped
dragging i've stopped
other than me being attached to the
relationship
is what i feel like i'm dragging now how
do you bring her joy
how do you how do you inject joy and
safety into her life
besides the fact that you're an
ex-marine you can kick people's ass like
how do you how do you inject
joy and safety into her life
i mean i try to spend time with her um
dedicate every tuesday to her okay try
to and what is it what does that
dedication look like
coaching opportunities no just spending
time with her i mean
the five love languages quality time and
words of affirmation are hurt okay um so
i try to
when she does cook dinner when she does
get dressed up or get dressed i try to
acknowledge it when
you know so i try to feed her her love
language and
but you see how you've just those two
examples when she achieves and does the
right things
then i let her know
she's not your child brother she's your
wife
and so here's the status of your
relationship okay and i don't want you
to mistake me i know you love this lady
and i know that you really want to do
this right
and there's a sacred moment when
a guy realizes i'm trying to fix this
engine in my car and all i have is a
wrench and a hammer
and these two tools aren't working oh
and by the way she's not an engine
in a car right and there's a
humility a humbleness a vulnerability
which is the anti-marine move right it
that's rolling over on your stomach and
on your back and exposing your belly and
saying you could hurt me
hun but i have to tell you i'm out of
tools
and i am going to go learn some new
tools i would love for you to come with
me
and she's probably not going to go man
when's the last time
you went and started talking to a
counselor on some new tools to help you
be a better man and a better husband a
better dad
i went to a counselor on my own i mean
covet had it
mobile right but i talked to a counselor
for about three months
and i got the advice that
she is who she is her past her past
actions are gonna be your future actions
and you've got to come to terms with it
or
yeah i get a new counselor that one
sucks
[Music]
sucks yeah the counselor's terrible
counselor i mean it kind of stuck with
me but
that's not that doesn't help every
single person can change
but they can only change if they have if
they are tethered into something
bigger and stronger than themselves
and it sounds like your wife is
exhausted
and detached because all she's been is a
series of
accomplishments achievements failures
she's got to live up to the standards of
her marine husband
and here's the thing here's the truth
you know that
if fill in the blank if she got control
of her money if she
exercised if she ate differently if she
fill in the blank
that those things would help her but
she's got to come to those things
on her own and she has to hear those
things from somebody that she can
actually hear him from
and she's got to be tethered into you
for connection right
she does not need any more information
from you she needs you
and so here's what you're going to i
want you to keep this picture and i've
used this
image a bunch i'm going to continue to
use it because it works
you guys have a relationship that's
ten plus years old three kids right
you're gonna have to excavate what you
have right now and rebuild something
from the floor up and if she won't
participate
in the early rounds of the architecture
and design
cool but i'd love for you guys to sit
down and
just dream together is this is this what
this is going to be for us
are we going to be back porch scrolling
through instagram for the rest of like
what what do you need what can what can
i
what can how can i bring you joy
and you can't make her do anything your
counselor was right on that but
what you can do is inject joy into your
home
and that comes from you doing the things
that you can control you working on your
thoughts your actions your behaviors
your way of treating people in the world
not lecturing her on what she eats but
you being a model not lecturing around
you know what you should be doing should
be exercising getting your finances
right but instead bringing your three
kids around for a budget day hooray and
bringing
i don't know reese's peanut butter cups
or whatever's gonna make your kids
excited about it you're gonna teach them
how to budget
and you're gonna do it with joy and with
laughter and with
fun not with military precision military
precision is important
but only when you have full trust does
that work
when you've signed it all over and your
wife's not signed on anymore
she's not signed on anymore and so
what's the best way
i mean you're headed towards if you're
not there already towards bitter
bitter resentment and then it's hard to
come back from that man
and so i want you to go about wooing
your wife again
i want you to go about finding the
things that
that get you all fired up to get your
heart beating again
that excites you about your kids excite
you about joy and love in your house
i want you to find another counselor
because the one you talk to sucks
anyone who says well it's just the way
it's going to be you have to get used to
it terrible
terrible you either leave or you both
grow together and i think every single
person can grow
a hundred percent of them if they have
attached
relationships if they are anchored into
something
solid right and dude i know you're tired
man i so know you're tired of hearing
your voice
so stop working on her i want you to
start working on you
and i want you to reverse engineer your
life find the places where you can be
patient where you can be kind where you
laugh a lot right where you forgive
other people including yourself
where you don't you don't identify with
the worst things you've done the
stupidest things you've said and the
dumbest decisions you've made
but you identify with the future where
you're taking these kids
how are you going to love this woman i
want you to grow that way brother
and there's a big awesome world there i
want you to grab a book
called i don't want to talk about it by
terrence real we'll put it in the show
notes we'll link to it
but don't you get it on amazon today i
want you to read that book
and if you're not a big reader get the
audio book and start from there
okay i don't want to talk about it by
terry real
terence real man thank you so much for
that call patrick i know that's hard
brother i know that's hard here's the
the the 30 000 foot ultimate umbrella
statement you can't fix her
you can fix you what i promise you is
if she's really in watching you
infuse and inject and create a platform
of joy and love in your home
with those kids a safe place that's not
a repair manual
but just someone loves her she's going
to say hey
something's different something's new
what's going on right and then you gotta
have in your head your or what moment
man at some point you gotta say i'm out
i know you feel shame that you failed
once you fail twice
i get that but you're gonna have to keep
that line for yourself too man because
you don't want to drag your kids down
you want to drag this woman down any
further